well it's a stacked [ __ ] division I
mean look you mean you still have your
well Romero at the top of the heap I
don't know what they're doing with him I
mean he was supposed to be fighting boa
Tina oh yeah Paulo Costello Costa Maha
Chien yeah who's a [ __ ] monster if
anybody is who's not on steroids who
looks like they're on steroids it's him
Wow
it's not that easy these days because
you've shot it but come on some of them
are on steroids
somebody God probably are Joe but who's
on okay you telling me that you don't
believe that you're Romero ever took a
steroid in his life I didn't say that
okay oh definitely in school I think
it's possible how's that fed she's
hitting on that I get it
so chop scenario for you to be in no no
no see commentary you [ __ ] honest bro
I believe it I'll say it and let's not
forget he tested positive there was not
holes
yes anytime somebody says it was a
tainted supplement yeah it's [ __ ]
you never tested positive friend never
tested positive in my life let me tell
you something I'm not a guy that scours
the back of everything I've read I'm a
careless [ __ ]
I really am I wish I wasn't but I am
I'll just go through my life doing what
I do I've been tested a million times
never come close okay some of the guys
they blow up the lab yeah you know
there's no smoke without fire you know
what I'm saying
I agree with you I agree with you I
remember there was talk years back
before you sada
there was talk of certain camps that
would hire guys who knew testing and
these guys would orchestrate a program
for these fighters to make sure that
they didn't get caught
right they would figure out ways to you
know to taper off but still keep your
gains and and make sure that you didn't
test positive at all and this was done
under the assumption that everyone else
was cheating as well and this was for a
long time that was how a lot of people
viewed the sport there was guys like you
BJ Penn there's a few guys that you just
knew weren't going to do anything it was
their word they said they were never
gonna do anything go and and they never
looked like they did anything you always
maintained the exact same physique
throughout your entire career well the
thing is
I I think where they started getting a
little weird and I don't want to bang on
about Stowers too much because that's
been a narrative that I have over yeah
you know yeah I've said my piece about
the daughter you know banging on about
it too much but I think where the waters
really got murky is when trt came in yes
I saw strong replacement therapy became
a thing and all you had to do was go see
doctor and said hey you know I can't get
a hard-on or whatever and all of a
sudden they sign you off or even TRT
know I know even worse you could take
steroids first and then come off of it
so your testosterone was low I'll really
go to a doctor and say I've low
testosterone of course yeah because it
messes up your natural production of
this is what God did guys took steroids
and then went in afterwards and said
they have low testosterone because they
were on steroids
sure not exactly so then it became legal
then you had all these guys coming out
there saying you know if I'm non TRT
I'll die I'll die and then they outlawed
it and then ten years later some of them
are still fighting to this day yes you
know so without naming names you know
who you are
shame on you about TRT Belko TRC Vitor
Belfort forever yeah it was when he was
on TRT he was a different kind of human
being he was just completely different
than he is in our circumstance oh yeah
looking back you can see that I mean
because when I for him I fought him on
TRT you fought him when he was Ethel the
super Vitor absolutely look like [ __ ]
The Incredible Hulk
he had butt muscles on his [ __ ]
eyebrows yeah looking back you can see
that you know but but at the time as a
fuzzy you gotta be you can't think like
that you know what I mean even doing
just doesn't do it justice that's
supposed to be before and after I'm just
recovering from a cold at the wake I'm a
little congested so I keep coughing the
real the real key that's better
that's way better that's much more
accurate and he's a guy who was known to
take things took things early in his
career everybody fought ran Dean when
you're 19 he was 240 pounds yeah yeah
exactly his neck start at the top of his
head yeah but yeah I remember there was
a
picture of us were both on the scale in
Brazil hmm and you know looking back now
he's a whole [ __ ] you know anyone else
with you seen this guy he's kind of big
ba ba ba ba ba but you don't think like
that at the time you can't as a fight if
you start having those thoughts those
doubts start looking at a fighter's
physique and thinking oh he looks good
you've already lost right now but in
hindsight you can look back and say holy
[ __ ]
what was I thinking you know this guy's
[ __ ] worried out of his mind
I remember on there I was trying to get
a rise out of him and he kept putting
his hand in my face I'm not a religious
guy and you know God bless anyone that
is you know I I mean that I respect
everyone's opinions but I'm not and as
we know Vito is heavenly religious and
he kept sticking his thing in my face he
was pissing me off so Vito come here
come here and he leans you and I said
there is no Jesus maybe there is maybe
there is you know me getting drops with
a head kick in the second round maybe
that was God for watching me who knows
what did he say some [ __ ] Portuguese
[ __ ]
[Laughter]